foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh what a thing to do
yeah well thank you so much to everybody
that purchased uh a solution and that's
what that is that's not just merch that
is something uh that we've been working
on and brainstorming for a long time and
it was essentially how do we get
involved how do we do more than what's
being done we don't want to sit on the
sidelines and make jokes we want to get
involved and actually have real results
and that's the difference between us and
a lot of other people not mentioning
names but most of the other podcasts out
there aren't Joe Rogan aren't getting
involved
and doing what we're doing for the
people so what we are doing is obviously
we're still in New York we're here at
gas digital Studios we're here for
fashion week we dropped the clothing
line every year I come for Fashion Week
in New York I'm kind of an ambassador
for many of the brands I was asked to
walk by uh Christian Dior the the the
house of Dior the legendary
um
fashion brand and I I didn't do it and I
didn't do it this year only because
I am participating I'm dropping my own
line and it's finally here it's finally
here for everybody and it is something
that people say to me you've done this
for so long you've been a member of the
fashion Community for so long and I have
and when when is your line coming out
this is at our basil in Miami over the
summer in the Hamptons people they would
bump into me onto the beach and they
would go hey not for nothing
but that's how they talk when the people
in the fashion industry uh like French
people when they bump into you on the
beach in like the south of France they
go hey not for nothing when is your line
gonna drop and the answer is now we have
a line of fashion for people
and
what's good about it is that we're
actually using the the profit
to help homelessness in Los Angeles
every four hundred thousand dollars of
profit
which is roughly probably eight hundred
thousand of Revenue because we're
operating at no and I mean really we're
operating at what kind of like a 50
margin right
and that's not great it's not ideal but
that's what we're operating at
is that really it no I'm dead serious
like 50 I think it's around 50. it's a
little higher but that's you know
what are you gonna do so 800 000 of
Revenue
400 000 a profit every four hundred
thousand dollars we are donating five
dollars to alleviate the burden
we're donating five dollars to right the
wrong we are donating five dollars to
build a better future for this country
that we live in we're not heartless
monsters
okay
and I want to do some simple math with
you because
this is every little bit helps did you
hear that when you were a kid ever
little bit helps I remember that
it's as American as saying as any
every little bit helps there is no uh
there remember there's no small roles
they're only small actors right yes
that's the saying yeah so there are no
small donations
there's nothing that is too small
you have to remember that because a lot
of people say to me well some people
have said to me are you are you giving
too much
and the answer is I don't think so but I
don't know but it to me I'd rather be on
the side of giving rather than the side
of taking
so now let's just with a five dollar
donation every roughly eight hundred
thousand of Revenue
five dollars
times a thousand dollars is five
thousand dollars okay that's a good
amount of money right so now eight
hundred thousand in Revenue times one
thousand
is eight hundred million dollars
if we can gross
on my store my merch store with my new
fashion line eight hundred million
dollars
of Revenue
of you know what I mean
what we will be doing is we will then
donate
well hold on because that's still only
400 million in profit right
so 400 million in profit
divided by
can you let's just because I want to set
goals if we make 400 million dollars in
profit what are we donating
uh so that would be one thousand times
five so that's five thousand dollars
but
but
so it's 800
0 oh yeah I am correct eight hundred
thousand in Revenue
I'm sorry 800 million in Revenue yes 400
million in profit five thousand dollars
to help homelessness in Los Angeles
get involved now because if I'm telling
you right now I feel good about this I
want to challenge other creators to do
it and this is my mission right now
and that's why I'm here in New York City
is why I I'm not back in my beautiful
Desert Oasis we've created for my studio
I'm roughing it here I'm roughing it
here because I believe in something and
I hope one day God I hope you believe in
something too that's all I'll say uh
where can they purchase this merchandise
and get it now and get a lot of it
because the more you order
here's what I want you to think about
the more clothing you order
the more money
gets gets put into a blanket fund for
homeless babies
a homeless baby will be swaddled in a
new blanket if you buy
where do they buy Tim dilloncomedy.com
it's right there Tim dilloncomedy.com go
to the site I want people to see how
easy it is show them you can show them
Francis show them Francis
show them how easy it is there it is and
there it is right there
fake business
we got it's a real Knife Fight out here
beautiful shirts and hoodies I wish them
well shirts and hoodies and why do we do
it we do it to help other people that's
why we're here others
the other thing I was reading about that
I find interesting is this article that
you had sent me about junk food and that
it is
no longer a thing
and we should stop focusing on it we
have to de-colonize that's right our
minds and one of the ways to do that I
had no idea how Progressive I was until
I read this article these are things I
have been doing for years I have been
making these kinds of choices for years
now I want you to tell people a little
bit about what's going on because there
is a company and they sell food
and they have hired a woman from Africa
yeah to tell people
that Ness worrying
about what you eat and what you put into
your body
is inherently bigoted right that's right
in some degree and you should eat
without guilt agreed and you should eat
without guilt and the people that are
hyper focused on
lean meats healthy fats proteins
you know the good carbs those people
are fascists that's right and those
people and by the way I I have suspected
that for a long time
because they kind of they kind of they
are a little you know strange
and but I had no idea
this was laid out beautifully
because occasionally you feel guilty
for eating something
and that is not right and actually your
body it is so deeply entrenched this
feeling of Shame and guilt and and
racism and you know all of this stuff
it's so deeply entrenched in US
sometimes after you eat something your
body will even feel sick
but that is because your body
is a racist
like even in your mind if you eat a
bunch of hojos
Donuts tasty cakes Suzy cues you know
yodels
Yankee Doodles
snowball whatever
could go on here for a while but you
might feel sick
but that is your body
reinforcing the type of racist
attitude bigoted attitude
now the company that hired who is this
this woman so her actual name is Kara
niem Diop yeah she is in this uh viral
uh sort of Instagram video here that La
Unified School District did share on
their Instagram well food neutrality the
LA School District now thank God
thank God because
kids should learn at a very young age
that there's absolutely no difference
between the foods
this is something that should be taught
to children as young as possible
there are no difference there's no
difference between a carrot and a carrot
cake
there's nothing it's only
Nazis Nazism
so tell us because the LA School
District
ran this ad or this promotion yeah they
shared it they promoted it and and tell
us about it because I'm very interested
in this so uh and Francis you can pull
up the video they have here but
basically what they're trying to explain
to the people they ever call you Franny
Lou
basically what they're trying to explain
to the to the students is that uh
there's food neutrality in the world I
like this there's not a bad idea
remember net neutrality oh yes what was
that uh because that was huge don't
don't Google it if you don't know what
it is
I think that neutrality was that was a
big deal that was a big deal but and
then everybody was like is it gonna
happen or not
so this is something else yeah this is
something totally different where
there's a misnomer that some foods are
bad and some foods are good yes and we
need to eradicate these ideas the only
there are only
three types of bad foods
foods that are rotten
okay foods that are filled with poison
and foods that I think well here's the
Define poison right right that's the
right but I like this so poison food
like I'm like like
Vladimir Putin when he poisoned uh
Alexander levchenko with polonium yes if
you were to put polonium in a taco it
would be bad yes but other than that
everything's good that's right okay so
food neutrality means I don't judge the
food I'm eating that's right I I eat
without guilt I want ice cream I eat it
I want cake I eat it I want candy I eat
at if I don't want vegetables I don't
eat them and I'm a child and I'm
learning this from my school district
this is what my school district is
telling me on their Instagram right
which I probably don't follow because no
young people are really on Instagram
they're all on Tick Tock watching I
don't know people get hit by cars but
whatever it's it's still may be
healthier than the Instagram promotion
being shoved down their throats by their
school district which is crazy and
people are so horrified by this they
looked into who this woman worked for
and on her LinkedIn page she works for
Mondelez International which is what
Chips Ahoy Oreo but so what that see to
me
I don't want to impugn her credibility
because she works for Chips Ahoy if
somebody that works for Oreo and Chips
Ahoy Nabisco whoever owns that Mondelez
uh you know if if they have
a a good non-racist idea
then let's hear it
can we actually play yeah can you play
the actual promo
can we get some can we get some sound on
this bad boy no are they moldy
a false standard of Health again aren't
you guilty bad culture photophobia and
systems of Oppression have created false
hierarchies of food and it shows up
everywhere for instance yes thought
patterns like earning food through
exercising or that dessert is the reward
for the punishment of eating vegetables
right remember that you do not need to
earn food we are all incorrectly caught
from a young age yes our size yes
therefore the foods that we eat the
markers of our self-worth correct
moralizing food can lead to harmful
relationships of food correct and
assorted eating instead of focusing on
good and bad choices try to approach
food with neutrality yes the only foods
that are bad for you right foods that
contain allergens poisonous and
contaminants or if someone's getting you
with it like a frozen food that
someone's hitting you with you would all
that could also hurt you like a frozen
steak if you hit someone
I mean this is right on I'm right on
with these people they're right on
because they get it if you eat a donut
or if you eat a salad the only
difference is how you look at it and
Society is judging you yeah that's the
really only difference in it like if you
sit down and have a bowl of donuts
instead of a salad for lunch that you
feel the same I'm telling you go and eat
a bowl of uh ice cream with candy for
lunch in an hour you'll feel the exact
same as if you have a salad it's the
same feeling
the only difference is if you eat a
salad you'll be awake
but you're still alive
see if you eat a lot of carbs or sugar
you go to sleep right afterwards and if
you eat a salad you don't but you're
still technically alive
after each meal so that's what they're
getting at you might be asleep
but you might be not as like responsive
in a vehicle
but you're still technically on Earth
you're in it you're still in the game
I mean I like I'm telling you right now
I know a lot of people are going to be
offended by this there's something I
like about it food neutrality being able
to just say I'm done with the shame I'm
done with the guilt if there's something
I see that I want to eat I'm gonna eat
it and I shouldn't like the idea that
vegetables are healthy and junk food
isn't is if what do they call it a false
food standard yeah it's a false food
stamp but that's correct
because it was put in into place it was
put into practice false hierarchies of
food false hierarchies of food these
things are all put into practice by by
people that were doctors or people that
were scientists and and that looked at
the way these Foods impacted your body
but they didn't take into account
lizzo and here come the big girls they
didn't take into account like you know
what I mean like there's so much more to
science than just the actual science of
it there's just a lot more fun to be had
and as a big person I'll tell you right
now I
I'm telling you I feel liberated by this
because I always felt
that when I was eating a lot of bad food
I was doing something wrong
and I felt bad and my body felt bad and
I felt like I was eating because I was
in pain but now I realize I'm actually
just being neutral
it's all neutral and nothing is really
bad or good and if I were to swap out
all of the bad foods I eat and let's
take and by the way I'd like to take
this a step further and include
narcotics
we have been told
by an unfair system that crack and
heroin
are inherently bad for you
this is a false
virtue this is a system set up
that doesn't recognize the realities
I want you to think about a radical term
narcotics neutrality
there is no I have a glass of water I'm
good I smoke meth I'm bad that isn't
real it shouldn't be real there is no
difference
between drinking
tea
a nice Earl Gray tea maybe a bit of
lavender on your porch and setting your
the back of your head on fire with a big
ball of glass there's no difference at
all the difference is that we have been
taught unhealthy attitudes about meth
that everyone who does it is Southern
that they do it in a barn that they're
all running around afterwards that
they're not trustworthy that they steal
your mail that they'll try to take your
identity that they're not good parents
we've been taught this by A system that
seeks to literally
criminalize meth culture
you're criminalizing math culture
which is groups of people getting
together and figuring out how to make
math in different open air spaces barns
abandoned buildings things like that it
is a culture it is not uh something that
can be criticized or criminalized by
people not participating in it I think
this is great this seems to be
a good idea
and I'm glad that they're putting it on
the Instagram page of where uh the LAUSD
Department page specifically their uh
the Los Angeles Unified School District
yeah it was on their Instagram page
thank God their human relations and
diversity Department shared it on
Instagram and the shame
when I went to my friend Ryan's house
um
we're talking
early in my life I was maybe in
eighth grade seventh grade
um his parents were alcoholics and they
lived in filth
and the coolest thing though about his
house he would get hit which was sad but
the coolest thing about and I don't
think he deserved it
I think they would just hit him
now but that being said he had like
Lucky Charms and we we in my house
people would be like hey
we can't eat that we could go Honey Nut
Cheerios but Lucky Charms like too much
but Ryan had the best
candy and the best cereal and everything
like that because his parents were early
adopters in this food neutrality they
knew they understood
that's just the way that this is the way
of the world and I'm I'm happy to
embrace it
man I love doing this podcast I love
talking to you guys 14 years ago in 2008
I was a mortgage guy can you believe
that reminds me of what's going on now
it's bad then it's bad now which is why
I really like these guys I've been
talking to them about them for a while
Masterworks you guys are gonna go crazy
for them I'm getting questions on how it
works here's what it is there aren't
Geniuses they use data to find Art they
think has the best chance of
appreciating and breaking into shares
for their members to invest in so you're
not paying out the ass to invest in
multi-million dollar art you can get the
same benefits and prices going up
Microsoft founder Paul Allen has a
billion dollars of art he hoarded why
he's not an idiot he knows this [ __ ] was
going to appreciate the proof is in the
pudding to date Masterworks has sold six
paintings for an average return of 29 to
investors guys 29 [ __ ] wow and because
Masterworks loves me there's a wait list
but they're hooking up all my listeners
with Priority Access to their platform
just go to masterworks.art Tim that's
masterworks.art Tim that's
masterworks.org Tim for Priority Access
see important regulation A disclosures
at masterworks.com CD I love Masterworks
I'm invested in it and I am very happy
with what's going on because I'm making
a lot of money from it and I'm seeing my
money make me money
and that's the best thing about money is
that it actually can make you money and
that's where I live in that world where
money makes money through ART which is
beautiful because art is is God and
money exactly you know what I mean and
that's what it is well it's really you
know and that's the whole thing
thank you
expressvpn is so important think about
all the times you've used Wi-Fi at a
coffee shop a hotel or even at your
parents house
without expressvpn every site you visit
could be logged in by the Admin of the
network and that's still true even when
you're going into incognito mode I mean
do you really want your parents to see
what you've been looking at what's more
your home internet provider can also see
and record your browsing data in the US
they're legally allowed to sell that
data to advertisers expressvpn is an app
that encrypts all of your network data
and reroutes it through a network of
secure servers so that your private
online activity stays just that private
expressvpn works on all of your devices
and is super easy to use the app
literally has one button you tap to
connect and your browsing activity is
secure from prying eyes so stop letting
strangers invade your online privacy
protect yourself at
expressvpn.com Tim Dillon use my Link at
expressvpn.com Tim Dillon to get an
extra three months free that's e x p r e
s s v p n.com slash Tim Dylan earn more
you use it everyone I know uses it
there's not what strangers I meet in
coffee houses go I'm using it everyone
uses it you're a fool if you don't isn't
that the case there's no reason to not
why not
you wouldn't not uh you would not
put your seat belt on in the car exactly
right
you're not
Rhonda Sanders has done something very
cruel yeah it's horrible it's really
horrible because what he did was he sent
a bunch of migrants to Martha's Vineyard
the season's over
are you like nuts
it's after Labor Day it's after
September first of all I have friends on
the vineyard I have friends on the cape
I have friends in Nantucket I have
friends in the Hamptons the season is
memorial through Labor stop it don't be
silly
yes fall is lovely in all of these
places and a small select group of
people will hang out you know because
work is more remote now and there's
nothing wrong with a winery a Vineyard
tour in the Hamptons of the fall or a
beautiful but but for the most part if
you want to get
really the full character of the area
dropped them off in the beginning of
Summer
so I don't get it
fall everybody spans in New York City
and then of course winter everybody goes
to Aspen or if they don't like or
Jackson Hole or Telluride or [ __ ] in
Breckenridge and if you don't like the
cold you have Saint barths and Anguilla
there's options why send them off season
to the vineyard it's cruel I mean it's
fine
it's not horrible clearly
but it's just not you know what I mean
like all the good parties are over all
the fun networking's done all you know
what I mean like all of the kind of
Summer Vibes the swimming the swimming
and The Vibes aren't happening like
so it's crazy it's so weird to me to
send like it's not the guy's a psychotic
[ __ ] it's like your people come to this
country and it's like okay The Vibes
right now are like pumpkins Fall New
England
calling somebody up at an Ivy League
school you haven't [ __ ] in a while and
going up to see them taking them to like
an old creaky in getting drunk drinking
mulled cider you know this is the thing
rainy days kind of like the vibe right
now is very much like I'm like LARPing
as a poor person kind of like it's like
big sweatshirts and hats and old jeans
and oh look I'm by the railroad now
photo you know what I mean and it's like
the family's con it's a getting our
adderall addiction kind of within range
because there is a shortage and then
just focusing on the holidays and like
what am I gonna be for Halloween where
am I gonna go like
it's like you're cannibalizing people's
Italy photos on Instagram and you're mad
at that still because they in late
August everybody was in Italy even Luis
Gomez
so it's just it angers me so it's like
so to bring these migrants
to Martha's Vineyard off season
isn't the deal like you explain to them
they're like the fall is like it's a
thing here it's a thing it's Halloween
it's New England it's sexy it's fun it's
you know what I mean like and and like
and then like explain to them like how
it works like how the social order
operates
now where do they now where do they go
because mother's Vineyard
nicely because more this Vineyard gets
it got rid of them because Martha's
Vineyard goes we're not at our best
right now we are literally preparing for
next year
and then and then Martha's Vineyard sent
them somewhere else Palm Beach where do
they go I believe they went to Cape Cod
Cape Cod okay but the reality is it's
like
late fall through the spring it's Palm
Beach
it's not
like what's wrong I don't get it
whatever I'm just here's my whole thing
with migrants
my only thing with migrants has always
been If You're Gonna Come
you have to assimilate into the culture
and the culture is
Hampton's Vineyard summer
Palm Beach Miami winter New York Spring
New York Fall New York Spring
potentially this is the culture
assimilate into the culture
duh
this is my biggest issue
immigrants come over here and they're
like oh we're just gonna go to Martha's
Vineyard in the fall it's like no you're
not
you have to assimilate into our culture
dummies
everybody goes to their second beach
house
in in like late June or even early July
they do the summer July to like the
second week of August then everybody
goes to Europe
wake up
so if these migrants don't want to like
fall in line then I don't know I don't
know
what's the point
are they nuts
what were they even doing there
I mean here's the deal if they're
looking at houses I can't be mad at them
to look at houses in the because you
want to look off season and you don't it
doesn't want to be too hot you don't
want to deal with traffic so if you're
looking if these migrants are looking at
houses off season trying to make a deal
I'm not mad at them I'm not mad at them
I'm literally not mad at them now were
you looking at homes I got my eye on a
few
the thing with the vineyard and I have
to explain this to that every migrant I
meet I have to explain to them I go
start start somewhere closer start on
the cape like the vineyard's a thing
it's just its own thing it's like
Nantucket like when I see a migrant I go
I know you want to live in Nantucket but
it's so far it's older money it's more
Finance like you just and they go okay
and I go listen to what I'm saying to
you
[Laughter]
that's the whole thing it's like these
migrants like I respect the Hustle but
you have to understand The Vineyards its
own Vibe it's its own thing it's not
forever I'm a Hamptons person
you might be a Vineyard person you might
be an Nantucket person you might go to
Crete you might go to Mykonos like no
one's judging where you spend your
Summers
but you have to experiment with a bunch
of different things
Here's a thought
Rent First
[Laughter]
migrants
listen to me don't make the mistake that
so many people have made
rent first it is a lot of money but you
understand like what you like what you
don't like
it's it's so simple it's like so many
people commit like I have a friend that
just bought them against and they're
like oh my God it's so far it's like why
didn't you rent in South First
why didn't you rent first you just
so I get so terrified for migrants when
they jump into things so that that's my
only concern and I think DeSantis is
pretty [ __ ] sadistic he's a little
sadistic to send someone off season to
the vineyard without giving them the
lecture that they should rent first
because you don't know where your summer
is going to be
I have friends in Malibu that would have
been happier if they stayed in Palos
Verdes it's just what it is
that's my my only concern for the
migrants
but that's again
that's where I'm at with this
everyone's like making a political it's
like it's inherently not political it's
about real estate and culture
everyone's like I left and right about
and understand this this has nothing to
do with Biden and DeSantis this has
everything to do with making good real
estate decisions
my apartment building that I'm that I'm
being um I'm leaving because I am uh
done with it
and I'm going elsewhere uh
has sent me this weird thing it's like
uh a a form where I have to vacate my
lease I've never heard of this and no
one else has ever heard of it either
you're just supposed to leave right but
they've put like this thing in the form
now get this up this is something that
the people at my apartment building 10
000 Santa Monica in Los Angeles which by
the way is a dump yeah I'm gonna say it
right now it's for rich people whose
lives did not work out it's for divorced
ads it's for Russian Instagram thoughts
it's for young Saudi royalty shout out
to the whole MBS and the whole fam
um it's you know all of that and it's
tick-tockers tick-tocking away but what
it is is it it is absolutely it is no
class it has no distinction it is an
undignified home for anyone with any
money it is undignified if you have any
type of pedigree if you've even been
near a school if you've even sat in the
same room with a book it's not for you
it is disgusting new money Zoo full of
junkies the police roamed the Halls
keeping the junkies in their cells the
people beat the [ __ ] out of each other
in their apartments and the cops have to
come and pick up all of the and then
sort the pills on the floor and give
each group each party the right amount
of medication to settle them down the
amenities the gym the pool they usually
don't work there always is that the
other thing
our friend Ida is there now and she's
impressed by it but uh she's impressed
by uh anything so
the reality is it's just not a nice
place now I didn't know that when I
moved in people told me that they said
it as a dark energy Steve Bing jumped
out of one of the windows and splattered
himself all over the valet now this is
these are all facts so I'm not saying
anything bad about the building if you
like to live in a building with junkies
where some of them occasionally jump out
of the windows and splatter themselves
all over the valet it is a good option
it is not a bad option if you like
excitement if you like drug addicts and
uh people that are famous for no reason
that have no Talent walking around
trying to figure out the coffee machine
because they're too high it's not a bad
idea
now I didn't like that so I'm moving on
now these people these people of the
building tried to get me can you pull
this up Francis yeah pull this up
because uh how dare they read this Ben
if you can
non-disparagement clause and this is
never heard of this ever a not and I'm
not disparaging it I'm being honest
solely simply honest
and you had to sign this because you're
moving out October 1st and they tricked
me they like threw this in there
tenant agree is that they will not
disparage ten thousand or any of their
officers directors or employees some of
the people that work there are nice yeah
I like a lot I like a lot of the people
that work there I'm talking exclusively
about the ones who do not steal your
food
foreign
for purposes of this paragraph disparage
shall mean any negative statement
whether written or oral about ten
thousand or its officers attractors or
employees uh you agree and acknowledge
that this non-disparagement provision is
a material term of this notice the
absence of which would have resulted in
the parties refusing to enter into this
notice
I don't know what that means what I'll
tell you is this is a dump and I'll
never stop saying it's a dump I will say
it everywhere on every platform I
actually wasn't going to say it until I
got that now I'm going to say it
everywhere I'm going to start every
media appearance I have talking about
what a dump it is and you didn't sign
that right I think I might have
no but because it's in East
no it's an e-signature it's an
e-signature that you can't take off I
tried to take it off
you can't delete it no you can't you
can't delete it but I responded I'm not
signing this it's America this is my
constitutional rights I'm a trans
indigenous you dumb [ __ ] I respond to
that but I do think my signatures on it
but I did because you can't delete the
easy signature but I emailed her
immediately take it back going I'm not
this isn't for me okay I said that well
and I called lawyers well what do you
mean well they can't these e-signatures
they sneak this [ __ ] in
but I emailed her I said I'm trans
indigenous and I'm not signing this it's
against my constitutional right you dumb
[ __ ]
that's what I said and that's what I
believe
you did actually write that I I saw that
I liked the building
I mean
my signature's on the line but I tried
to I tried to delete it like nine times
and can't get me I got too many [ __ ]
lawyers they don't want to get into a
high profile battle with me I will do a
battle with them we'll get in a high
profile legal bad they don't want it
they don't want that smoke as the as the
drill RAP Community would say
they'll just back off you think well
yeah
I don't even lit I'm leaving yeah I'm
not even supposed to be there I'm done
my friend Ida is there killer if you
want to really hurt me go like if they
want to if they want to just throw her
out of the just Bing her
Binger
Binger right over the balcony
um but that's the I would like to say
one positive thing about you as a
resident there if they're listening to
this you're one of the few people paying
rent I just do want to put that out
there because everyone else is on drugs
right
yeah
right the finishes suck as a luxury
building that's not good they need to do
they need to turn flip a condo they need
to go in there with new finishes they're
getting a lot of money right now I
understand it because people you know
get divorced and they have to bring
their sad [ __ ] Rich ass family just
to take the elevator up and go remember
when we were a family but Dad Dad just
you know Christmas wasn't enough for Dad
or Chris I mean Hanukkah but whatever it
wasn't enough for dad dad needed to go
see the [ __ ] and now we live in this
apartment and isn't the view nice oh
look at the view it's so nice remember
the the old view used to have the one of
your mother
and the family well we don't have that
view anymore but look you can see the
ocean kind of through the smog a little
not really
I wish everyone well it's a good
building and if you if you need it it's
good for you
moving on
moving on
ship station is so important because
right now everybody's doing online
Commerce e-commerce is driving the
economy I mean literally everybody's
working from home people are starting
their own small businesses but what do
they need to do they need to focus on
try the driving force of that business
which is creativity Ingenuity Innovation
coming up with great products great
sales strategies marketing here's what
they shouldn't be worrying about the
back office shipping keeping track of
orders what got shipped what didn't
that's where ship station comes in
the best time to prepare for growth is
before the opportunity arrives
especially for online businesses ship
station sets you up for growth by
directly integrating with every shopping
cart and storefront so your products are
easier to find easier to manage and
easier to get into the hands of happy
customers don't wait until you're
drowning in order to find the right
shipping solution upgrade to ship
station today I mean it's great they
integrate with every platform Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify they make it easy to
manage all your shipping from one simple
dashboard maximize your sales with
minimal effort and what are they going
to do for me if you go to
shipstation.com today and sign up with
promo code Tim Dylan for free 60-day
trial start today and set up before the
biggest shipping season of the year
right ship station
s-h-i-p-s-t-a-t-i-o-n.com
shipstation.com promo code Tim Dillon
60-day free trial that's two months free
visit shipstation.com and click the
microphone at the top and type in code
Tim Dillon and you know we're using this
to actually are we we're using it all
the time yes it's been great especially
as shipping becomes more complicated I
mean will you stop at the railroads and
everything nuts will you stop it
there's not much you know there's not
much to do here except move on and just
yeah you know and uh and to believe so
many children are back at school now and
so many of them should be listening to
our how to be popular episode one of the
most classic things we've ever done
um because what it does is it lays out
it lays out
uh I was Andrew taped before Andrew I
was telling people here's how to be
popular here's how to be cool
and I was laying out a practical way for
kids to attain levels of popularity that
they had been denied and I had given
them a good road map about choosing a
personality finding the weak Link in the
popular group and becoming their best
friend ultimately replacing them is what
happens you don't go for the Star
Quarterback you don't go over the head
cheerleader you go for the guy that's
just on the periphery who's still in you
befriend him or her and then replace
them and you work your way up I mean
this is such a great episode called how
to be popular on the patreon you can
find it but it is so amazing I almost
want to animate it oh yeah yeah it is I
almost want to animate it and put it out
as some type of cartoon
some type of animated short because it
is such an important thing most people
right now that are in school are
you know woefully under prepared
unprepared really for the rigors of
social life
uh how to be someone that people want to
hang out with how to be cool
um you know and I said and I said it was
quite radical when I said it if you have
no friends it is your fault and that was
a big moment in American culture because
we have wrongly believed that the
friendless are like Geniuses who are
waiting to be discovered uh that they're
going to produce some type of art that
shifts the culture
no no no no no uh many of them are
exactly where you are where they are
still without friends uh they just get
older they don't they don't become the
South Park creators in certain very rare
instances some people do but in most
instances your misery will just continue
and compound so what you should do is
reach out I mean
with the world the way it is today if
you could not get some type of friend
group it really is your fault you know
half of 90 percent of this is all online
you don't really even have to leave your
house so you should be able to get some
friend group so that episode how to be
popular was a big big episode that
people will stop me in the street and go
my child listened to this and I I've
made my child sit down and listen to
this episode of your podcast because it
was so instructive
it's amazing
and and it literally
like one of the things I said is choose
a personality because this is essential
and one of them is like person whose
parent died this is a personality that
is available to you someone whose father
died or and then it never ends with that
it'd be it's the beginning middle and
end of who you are my father's dad my
dad's dad I love my dad every Instagram
post is Dad love you Dad at the grave
again with Dad
that is gone but I love him
you're a two-year-old and you're in
Dad's arms and daddy love me there was
nobody that loved me like that and I
love that and that is a fine personality
for a person to have and literally
people introduce you like this is Alicia
her father is dead
and that's what she brings to the table
her father's dead so every time anything
about anybody comes up about their dad
or whatever we look at her we go are you
okay
and she's like God that's the LIE yeah
and you go of course it is
but that's a personality
write a list of them I had a list of
personal and you have to be one of these
personalities you have to be you don't
have a choice you cannot create your own
thing who are you Picasso you choose a
personality [ __ ]
uh you know white guy who is literally
black gay guy with a girlfriend these
are updated ones by the way I I mean I
know Comics who are gay with girlfriends
they're like stop it in the name I love
my [ __ ] like gay guy with a girl it's
fine she wants it too women are idiots
most of them not all of them some of
them I don't mean most of them I mean in
in love they're idiots not in other
places women get dumb with love let me
let me let me let me really explain what
I mean here because I'm not like a
massages women can be very smart except
when it comes to love they go for men
that are so much lower than them in many
cases it's amazing which is why this in
cell [ __ ] I never really understood
these guys are like I can't get laid and
these women they just want stock Brokers
not all of them you know how many women
I know who are with total zeros you know
how many women I know who have literally
mortgaged their entire future on a
[ __ ] loser all the time it happens
all the time and especially when they're
young when they're in high school so
this idea that you have to be like that
a knight in shining armor is just not
true right so if you're dating a gay guy
as a woman you're an idiot you deserve
it you like it it's it is what it is but
it but that is a guy straight you're a
gay theater guy and maybe you're
straight here's what's even sadder
you're actually straight
you're actually straight and you're like
in theater and you're like I hope I get
it and you're actually there are those
people it's like a freak it's an
accident in the lab you be like if I
suck [ __ ] you have to like the cop
should come to your house and drag you
out of it and make you suck someone off
on the lawn because there are guys that
are so gay that it's amazing but they
like [ __ ] women it's crazy and it
happens
but that's a personality to be
this is a personality to be
being comfortable in your own skin is
important so if you're a white guy but
you want to be a drill rapper fine
it's okay just adopt that personality if
you're a straight gay whatever fine
adopt that personality
quiet non-binary girl who isn't a girl
but you know what I mean the quiet
non-binary entity that wears Doc Martens
and has like sewage green hair is a
thing you can be that but you have to be
that
commit to that
but you have to be you can't show up one
day with like big tits and blonde hair
you have to choose it and you go this is
what I am
you have to just choose it you know
these were all some of these are updated
because you know things change all the
time
hot guy
who's going to destroy his life no
matter what
that's a person good looking guy who
like Grunts and smirks and doesn't
really talk and every decision he makes
brings him close closer to his
inevitable and sudden and absolute
certainty of a violent death
every decision he makes brings him one
step closer to his death that is a
person that you can be but die do it go
all the way
fat girl
with dietary restrictions
fat girl who makes it uncomfortable for
Everyone by telling them that you're
vegan
gluten free you don't eat dairy you're
you've got all these things yet you
still are a mammoth whale somehow
but you don't eat anything but you
somehow still are fatter than everyone
else and tell them all the time tell
them Guy this is who I am this is a
personality that you can be but you have
to stick with it don't lose weight
and don't get less annoying be a fat
girl with dietary restrictions and tell
people all the time
be like when they say oh I'm gonna go
get the Taco Bell go yeah yeah
I don't need that but be a house while
you say it be an absolute house
yeah Taco Bell it's gross I don't even
do that
but just be the blob while you say it
literally be [ __ ] say it like you
were sitting on [ __ ] job of the
Hutt's throne
but that's a personality
damaged girl who just moved here that's
a personality you don't know her life
here's a hint it's actually fine
it's fine
she claims she used to be a cutter but
there's no marks on her
she's got like this weird pass a
shrouded mystery but it's actually not
she's actually fine she's a disgusting
narcissist who wants the world to
celebrate her for her looks and her
personality
um but she doesn't get that so she has
created she's cloaked herself in mystery
all of it isn't true it's okay she's the
damaged girl that just moved here from
another town she was a third string
cheerleader somewhere else but now she
showed up with purple hair and she's
listening to Fiona Apple and she's like
you know she's been through it and
through it means the move it means
nothing else she's she's but that's a
personality you can be yeah you can be
that you can you can absolutely be that
and it's not a big deal these are things
you have to stick with you have to be
this you have to be this thing and
everyone's going to remember you as this
thing and then when you graduate you
could be another thing but but to be
popular is to be consistent build a
[ __ ] brand when you're out there it's
important to build a brand not everybody
can be everything at all times to all
people
build a brand
true
deeply deeply deeply deeply important
consistently
show your your life in one digestible uh
way to people they have to be able to
digest it and go okay I get what this is
I get what this is it can't be too
complex I understand what this is this
makes sense to me
you know I got it so that's just a
little quick primer but there's so much
more I mean so much more in the episode
how to be popular on patreon because
what it does is it crystallizes all of
my points it goes back to the old
archetypes you can sit down with your
children and literally go who are you
going to be this year and you every
summer you can kind of change
but you have to commit for a year
and you can sit down with the kids and
go who are you going to be this year
look at me who are you gonna be
who have you decided to be
are you going to be a jock are you going
to be kind of a smart aloof are you
going to be aloof do you even know how
to be aloof aloof is not for ugly people
good looking people have the option of
being aloof meaning kind of with it kind
of not
ugly people have to work very very hard
to just get into the game
they have to work very very that's why
like the ugly girls are they
because they're always and the ugly guys
are always online trying to get better
at things like shooting
now they have to have hobbies and
Passions
these are just the facts of life don't
get mad at me I didn't make them up I'm
only uh illustrating them I'm only
telling people the way things are people
get mad at me they get angry like no but
I do like that we're now telling kids to
be as fat as possible to eat whatever
they want to not be guilty to just be
big fat pigs and the junk food industry
it's gonna get awkward you know one day
it'll be awkward I don't know when
that'll be it's gonna be awkward you
know that that lizzo big girl show is
awkward because they're doing the dances
and they can't breathe and they're like
and we're celebrating it it's not
happenstance we're saying good good good
this is good not breathing is good your
joints buckling under pressure is good
injuries and all that it's good that's
good good yeah that lady's name in the
video is at Savage fatty or something
like that but yeah but own it I get it
just make that paper the point is it's
gonna get awkward
it'll eventually get awkward because
we're now at a point where they're
saying models that are plus size aren't
plus size enough
so it will get to a point where
everybody is in a wheelchair
on a fashion runway or
you know there will be a point where
everybody and not for a genuine
disability because they're just so fat
that they literally have to be in a
wheelchair and then you wonder if people
at Nabisco like go like like is there at
any point do the CEOs of these junk food
companies at any point do they get
uncomfortable by the level of fat
do they get like if this was like a
black mirror or Twilight Zone episode
like the CEOs of these companies should
be just like
set upon by fat people and eaten they
should be taken out of their cars like
the CEO of Mondelez or any of these
places their cars should be stopped they
should be dragged out by fat people and
literally eaten they should be eaten by
the thing they've created they should be
torn limb by limb and cooked by the
thing they've created is there any
chance that that happens I don't know
but that is literally the only hope
it is the only hope here because we've
gone so and listen fat people should not
be the constant butt of jokes it
shouldn't be like it was in the 80s
where people you know you're not respect
I don't believe you should shame people
and uh be overtly hostile to people
but I do believe we're going in a
direction that is uh insane unhealthy
weird
it's weird to destroy all beauty
standards in a society sex is different
than Beauty people can get off to all
kinds of weird [ __ ]
some of the least attractive people I
know have the most sex and probably the
best sex
what I'm saying is that it's odd that
we're in this place that we're going to
this place where it is a virtuous to be
fat
it's not just something that happened or
something that you've done it's it's a
virtuous it's good it's something to be
proud of I don't know that you should be
proud of it the same way you shouldn't
be proud of being Italian or any dumb
thing right like being fat or Italian
dumb things you shouldn't be proud of
them because they're dumb
they both involve sauce
you should be proud of being an
individual
that's what you should be proud of
Tim Dillon comedy.com for all of your
fashion needs are closed only some of
them go up to three acts some of the
t-shirts might go up to more you know
because there are things it's there's
other things we might do a bigger shirt
if you're a really big guy we get it the
shirts go up to I think four though it
might go up to four the hoodie what do
we got here tell them the reality it's
hard to get a footy a hoodie that goes
up to 4X but you get the shirts there in
4X if you want a 4X hoodie you got to go
to DXL and you got to spend that cash
though we're gonna try to get a 4X
hoodie
um you know we're trying but it's just
it's an economic issue we're trying to
help homeless people
you know
timbulaccomedy.com go and get the go and
get it dig in
we're working on England by the way but
because it's not our fault it's brexit
it's brexit there's all kinds of
problems I didn't do it things get stuck
at Customs dude it's the IRA
you got people blowing up baby carriages
you got Protestants over there going
nuts you got the Catholics you got all
kinds of issues I'm a working man
I'm gonna get involved in some Civil War
what about Norway and and uh Amsterdam
people are screaming at me they're going
nuts Finland I think what about Finland
I think we have Europe we have Europe do
we have Europe I think is that even
Europe is Scandinavia Europe for the
purposes of delivery what else would it
be for the purposes of delivery I want
to be Asia I don't know what it is I'm
talking about delivery
I'm talking about getting the merch into
the people's hands putting the
merchandise into the people's hands
so that they can go solve [ __ ] home
we're solving homelessness with the
money
it would be easy for me to take all the
[ __ ] money and do nice things with
you dumb [ __ ] the reason I'm doing this
whole entire the reason I got in the
comedy was then homelessness
that's why I started this 12 years ago
to end homelessness
it's all been a project of leading me to
that
everyone in this business got into it to
make to be good
everybody from Jennifer Lawrence
everyone right on down everybody got
into this to end racism and end
homelessness
we just on the way we made a couple of
mill
what do you got to say about this now uh
I just asked Brandon if we ship but I
believe we do ship to these places
Finland
I hope we do I love those places
but we delivered Europe or sorry
delivers the wrong word that sounds so
stupid we ship
we shipped we ship we don't deliver
that's what I mean shipping well I was
saying delivery oh you were well because
it makes people feel it feel they feel
comfortable shipping makes them feel
like oh my God boats are involved the
Navy is China attacking Taiwan it's
complex delivery means oh it's a hot
pizza oh it's a sweatshirt like I'm
trying to use words that make them feel
comfortable I'm studied in this Arena
you were just popping off at the hip
confusing them frightening them shipping
shipping join the Navy no delivery you
open up your door there it is hot and
fresh out of the oven a hoodie to help
homeless people in Los Angeles
California be Stars
to help homeless people be Stars
because the first step to being a star
is having a home and then it all comes
together dummy
it's a timberlandcomedy.com for the
merge keep buying it uh Tim J Dillon on
Instagram and Twitter and we do not have
a tick tock I'm locked out I change
phone numbers but you promised me that
we're gonna start building something on
Tick Tock we've never done you'd never
do anything we're in touch with their
support to to get but you've never done
it like we it's essential for people
right now to get famous and get big is
to be on Tick Tock more and you've never
done it you really don't do it
right we we gave up on Tick Tock who's
we I would say I've been telling you to
do it we used to we made content there
for a while this is a fashion impression
but no it it's always me and I'm just
telling you can you cut the podcast up
and put it on Tick Tock absolutely
because other people are doing it and
you're not even doing you're like oh it
will get banned but that's a lie it's
just because you're lazy no my I tried
to upload it on mine because I have one
yeah it immediately got flagged for
child abuse for what what was I saying
it was the Remember The Talky remember
Taki the little guy from uh the ant word
yeah oh that that freak they they uh
like abused or whatever within 20
seconds they had to evaluate if my cat
was even like sharing don't share that I
mean just think a little bit can you
think a little bit
maybe stop getting drunk and bawling
with your wife every night and work a
little bit the lady that we know at Tick
Tock I said would they be okay with most
of the content on the podcast and she
was like well she's like you need to you
know bleep most of that and like don't
share most stuff you know well that
sounds like good marching orders it
sounds like she's giving you a road map
of things to do and instead you're
instead going and buying a bottle of
alcohol sitting in a bowling alley
parking lot with your wife in the valley
getting drunk and then putting pouring
booze into grape slushies and then going
and bowling that's where your life is
it's true that's what he does he's just
drunk with his wife they love bowling
they love slushies and they just sit
there and they eat they eat nacho cheese
with those winter which is nice
sometimes you get a bowling alley with
the Scoops because the cheese is hot it
is nice but it comes right out of the
machine
99 certain yes but Brennan is confirming
okay good well so get it if you're in
Scandinavia
yeah he's taxing me too he's drunk
everybody's drunk except me everybody's
a big drug addict except me the bowling
alley sounds great
sounds like a fun time
yeah I mean listen slushies nachos vodka
slipping I do not present certain yeah
well I mean listen I just want you to do
a little work just a tiny bit of work
to all the migrants in Mars's Vineyard
holler at me
because I've been through it I know what
it is
I will put you in contact with people
that move real that move real estate out
there
that know what they're doing if you're
interested in a seasonal rental next
summer people literally start looking
during Christmas
it is more competitive than you think
call me
you know what I mean
and there's also no shape like if you
want to go to Paris there's also a new
shame in it there's literally no shame
in it if you're like I want to do July
in Paris it's not hey there's no right
or wrong right now you know and that's
what people need to understand but
Rhonda said is sending you their off
season was cruel
and I get it
I get it so
here's another here's another thing and
again this is for the migrants
for the migrants that are in Martha's
Vineyard right now
so few properties there are turnkey
because of how old they are
but I'm telling you right now
you can find help
easily they can do things on the cheap
wink wink
for the migrants
I'm just saying
that there are a lot of
undocumented people
foreign
that will help you
do the things you need to your house
if you need that wink wink nudge nudge
to the migrants that are coming looking
real estate right now in the vineyard I
get it I like the vineyard too it's not
for me I'm more of a hamster but like I
got respective in here like we all I see
you
I see you I see the dream of a
Northeastern summer I understand what it
is I understand the dream of a
Northeastern summer and I know what you
want and I get it you're like Ugh Malibu
so new money so grotesque so tragedy
it's weed I'm not into any of it you're
like Northeastern are the kids at
sailing Camp yes they are lobsters
Clambake I get it we're with you we're
with hey we're with you just rent first
for the love of God
rent first and see like where do you
want to be
where do you want to be on the vineyard
you know there's so many even the thing
is not that big it's pretty [ __ ] big
you know what I mean so it's like a very
interesting layout of options to have
and that's why
you know are you a cottage person are
you a walk to the beach person are you
more of do you want a larger home are
you entertaining
hey
so are you in Oak Bluffs are you a
cottage in Oak Bluffs who knows
who knows
I get it
I get it I get and I know it's scary
right now I know for Martha's Vineyard
migrants it's scary because inventory is
low and they want to make a choice they
can live in with their families and
really enjoy and make money off of and
it's difficult it's very very hard so I
understand it's so scary
being a migrant where do they come from
these migrants oh for uh Cuba uh
everywhere everywhere but they were they
were shipped from Florida ship that
ships the wrong word but you know what I
mean what do you mean Cuba uh like they
were Cuban they were I could pull up
exactly what what do we mean by like
migrant uh let's see here so I thought
it was like
these are not
they're not these are not people from
like Connecticut
uh uh no like Oh you mean like outside
of no these are so the uh let's see here
yeah
like carpet backer where it's like oh
you're from Florida but you're where
they're going to like to San just
sending you to the vineyard oh no that's
not this what is this this is uh like
people that immigrated To America that
are like
uh I guess undocumented workers things
like that
Cuba Venezuela countries like that
oh so this is like people from outside
of America
these are not people looking for summer
homes
that's what I'm pulling up
oh
I can double check because my I thought
it was my I thought migrants where
there's just these are people looking
oh I'm like confused
I'm very confused right now
uh it says the migrants transported to
Martha's Vineyard are says here
Venezuelans who recently crossed the
Southwest border is that where they have
those like spotlights the big spiders
yeah there's big spiders Arachnophobia
yeah
uh
says the migrants who were dropped off
at vice president Kamala Harris's home
were colum from Colombia Cuba Guyana
well listen I don't know what's going on
Panama I don't know what's going on I
have a lot of friends in the vineyard
and I just
I'm very confused right now as as well
as many other people
let's just go buy the merch
right now I I thought these people were
from Connecticut
this is [ __ ] insane
they're not from Connecticut
well this is not going to work at all
Tim Dylan comedy.com buy the hoodie